después de los terremotos en Siria y
Turquía el 6 de febrero el saldo de
35,000 fallecidos es una de las mayores
preocupaciones pero para muchos el tema
se aleja de lo humanitario las
elecciones turcas deberían ocurrir en
mayo y un debilitado reyecta allí
verdogan enfrenta críticas por una
respuesta ineficiente hace 20 años el
mandatario llegó al poder con la promesa
de leyes contra terremotos Mientras
tanto en Siria Los cascos blancos
denuncian que el gobierno de bashara
lasad con casi 23 años en el poder
recibe ayuda humanitaria de todo el
mundo pero no permite su paso hasta las
zonas en el Noroeste dominadas por los
Rebeldes Solo dos convoyes han llegado a
través de Turquía a regiones que ya han
soportado más de 11 años de guerra y
ahora los terremotos Andrea Chamorro
analista en relaciones internacionales y
especializada en África y Oriente medio
nos acompaña con el análisis Andrea
gracias a usted por estar en directo a
América
Hola un placer estar aquí mira Andrea el
escenario del terremoto no ayuda a
erdogan que en mayo enfrentaría las
elecciones ella venía con la carga de
una inflación que superó el 50%
el valor de la lira en picada y ahora la
oposición también le increpa por la
reacción gubernamental a la tragedia
usted cómo evalúa la reacción de erdogan
pues la reacción ha recibido una gran
cantidad de críticas debido a algo mucho
que tardó en dar una respuesta en lo
mucho que te hacen trasladarse a las a
las zonas afectadas y que las ayudas
están llegando muy lentamente a pesar de
que prometió una ayuda de 500 euros Cada
ciudadano y que se reconstruyan los
edificios en un año es muy difícil que
se llega a producirse debido ya la
delicada economía eh de Turquía al mismo
tiempo en los partidos de oposición se
trasladaron las zonas de conflicto digo
las zonas afectadas todavía más deprisa
quedogan y ya fue duramente criticado
por la propia debido a unas estrategias
de comunicación de dogan era su cercanía
con el pueblo que fue uno de las cosas
que le llevó al poder como usted decía
hace 20 años pero es que se demoró dos
días en visitar la zona de desastre y ni
siquiera fue al epicentro en su primera
visita ahora erdogan llegó al poder hace
20 años en 1999 después del temblor lo
que hizo caer en desgracia el anterior
gobierno por su mal manejo y él prometió
leyes antiterremotos y además
transparencia sin embargo 20 años
después la gente se pregunta qué pasó
con esas promesas porque 20 años después
se repite una tragedia igual o peor que
la del año 1999
la cuestión como usted decía es que
erdogaño va al poder primero como Primer
Ministro como presidente ofreciendo una
imagen renovadora alejada de las élites
que tan hastiadas tenían ya a la
población ofreciendo una imagen de
islamismo moderado de una mayor cercanía
a la población de devolverle el dinero y
las prestaciones sociales que que habían
perdido con los años anteriores sin
embargo
como hemos podido ver con el paso de los
años no solo esto no se ha cumplido sino
que ha ido a peor debido al
empeoramiento de la calidad democrática
llegando a ser un sistema muy
autoritario y en el que la calidad de
vida de la población cada vez va peor
teniendo en cuenta la inflación y el
debilitamiento de la economía por lo que
erdogan no son los que no haya cumplido
lo que se prometió hace 20 años sino que
la situación está casi peor sólo por ya
el detrimento de la Democracia con esta
cuestión
como ya decían lo uno de los puntos más
llamativos en Turquía han sido la
cantidad de edificios que sean de ruido
y que esta cuestión ya venía desde hace
largo tiempo ya que la propia falla que
se asienta en Turquía ha provocado
terremotos de una gran mortalidad Por lo
cual los edificios deberían estar
preparados para soportar estos
terremotos lo que ha ocurrido es que no
estaban preparados muchos se infringían
las normativas y esto era con el
beneplácito del gobierno llegando a ver
amnistías como la de 2018 que reportaba
muchos beneficios al gobierno y aunque
se supiese que los edificios no cumplían
la normativa para terremotos está no se
aplicaban los edificios no se derruían y
continuaban en un solo que ha convertido
que se que los edificios se envasen y
que haya habido toda esta mortalidad que
estamos viendo ahora Andrea para que se
hagan una idea en el temblor de 1999
hubo entre 17.000 y 35.000 víctimas el
día de hoy ya alcanzamos a cuatro mil
solo en Turquía Así que en las
características son similares y la
respuesta de erdogan ha sido el arresto
a 131 personas presuntamente culpables
de las construcciones que él mismo
autorizó desde el inicio de su gobierno
ahora mi última pregunta sobre Turquía
porque también quiero hablarle de Siria
muy rápidamente es Se podrían aplazar
las elecciones
pues es una cuestión que ahora mismo
está sobre la mesa porque erdogan se
empieza a quedar sin opciones pero sin
embargo como ya digo el sistema se ha
ido
construyendo de tal manera en estos 20
años que erdogan tiene muchísimos
mecanismos para forzar a que se pueda
llegar a dar un eh una tras electoral
pero tendría que ser un motivo de
muchísimo peso para que se llegase a
plazar O sea no solo una cuestión
exterior como podría ser una operación
exterior en Siria que le gusta mucho
hacerla sino tenía que ser un motivo de
gran peso nacional la cuestión es que
ahora mismo no habría uno y
probablemente se intenten que no se
aplacen muy bien Ahora del lado sirio la
ayuda ha llegado de forma absolutamente
desigual Los cascos blancos denuncian
que bachara al azar recibe ayuda
internacional de todos los países por
avión pero que no permite que pase al
noroeste del país y aquí le pregunto
esto es una estrategia más en el marco
de 11 años de guerra civil
la cuestión es que ahora mismo estaba
siendo muy difícil que la ayuda
humanitaria acceda aunque como ya dijo
usted que Turquía haya abierto las
fronteras para que pasen porque al mismo
tiempo no está llegando a las zonas de
conflicto en tanto en cuanto que tampoco
la de Naciones Unidas consigue llegar
porque los mecanismos están siendo muy
lentos y Siria no está recibiendo la
misma cantidad de ayuda humanitaria y
accede a las zonas de conflicto está
siendo muy complicado bien y denuncian
que los mismos cascos blancos que es la
burocracia de la ONU la que impide la
llegada de ayuda y que no hay excusa
para que no alcancen pues los
suministros para allá y es que claro se
reportan cerca de cuatro mil víctimas en
Siria pero esa cifra podría no ser
realista porque es que no hay presencia
suficiente de organismos internacionales
allá
sí es una de las cuestiones que más nos
está llamando la atención la disparidad
entre víctimas ya que Turquía se acerca
estaba entre los entornos 27.028.000
mientras que en Siria 3000 la cifra está
siendo muy difícil de contabilizar
debido a eso a la poca presencia de
instituciones internacionales o del
propio gobierno en esa región ya que
está controlada por otros grupos